Professor John Rogers:
I want to revisit just for
a moment the opening of the
invocation to holy light,
which is of course,
as you know,
at the beginning of Book Three
of Paradise Lost.
This page 257 of the Hughes.
This is how Milton begins the
invocation, as you remember:
"Hail holy Light,
offspring of Heav'n first-born,
/ Or of th' Eternal Coeternal
beam, / May I express thee
unblam'd?"
You'll remember that last week
we looked at Milton's desire to
imagine himself unblamed or in
some way unblamable for the
condition of his blindness.
Milton had for years gone out
of his way to justify himself
before his nation and before his
God;
but that was only one way to
read this line,
"May I," and this question,
"May I express the unblam'd?"
"Unblam'd," it seems to me,
can just as easily modify the
"holy Light" being addressed by
the poet.
It can correspond to the "thee"
as well as the "I" in that
question.
It's this alternative
syntactical possibility that I
want to explore in this lecture.
I'll be focusing on the status
of this poem as an attempt to
exculpate not only this poet but
this poet's God,
to render God blameless for the
range of losses that this epic
so eloquently
enumerates.Look at the
sentence that I've written on
the board from Dr.
Johnson's Life of
Milton.
His purpose was the most
useful and the most arduous;
to vindicate the ways of God
to man [it continues,
I'll finish the sentence];
to shew the reasonableness of
religion, and the necessity of
obedience to the Divine
Law.
I'll read it one more time
His purpose was the most
useful and the most arduous;
to vindicate the ways of God
to man;
to shew the reasonableness of
religion, and the necessity of
obedience to the Divine
Law.
Johnson here is clearly
thinking of Milton's ambition of
producing a theodicy,
an attempt to justify the ways
of God to men,
and I think he's right to
identify Milton's theodicy as
really one of the central tasks
of the poem.
Milton seems genuinely sincere
in wanting to provide a rational
and reasonable account of the
ways of God;
but you've probably noticed
that Johnson's gotten his
quotation wrong.
He may have gotten his
quotation wrong because he is
not thinking directly of the
Milton,
but he's thinking of Alexander
Pope's earlier thinking of the
Milton from Pope's great poem
The Essay on Man.
Pope gets it wrong as well.
Milton, of course,
doesn't end the opening
invocation to Book One of
Paradise Lost with the
claim that he will assert
eternal providence and
vindicate the ways of God
to men.
Milton says that he will
justify the ways of God to
men.
I think it's slight but
nonetheless there's a difference
between these two words,
and I think there's something
instructive here about Johnson's
slip and perhaps something
instructive,
too, about Alexander Pope's
slip a few decades
before.Now when Milton says
that he'll justify God's ways,
I think he means simply that he
will account for the justice of
God's ways and he will
demonstrate their
justifiability,
but to vindicate God's ways --
vindicate is a slightly
different word,
although they could certainly
be seen as synonyms -- to
vindicate God's ways is,
I would imagine,
to presuppose at the outset
that God is under some suspicion
of guilt,
that he's assumed to have done
something wrong and that it's
our job to vindicate him or to
get him off the hook.
Milton of course can't himself,
and doesn't rightly,
use the word "vindicated."
It's too prejudicial.
It seems on some level to
criminalize God's behavior in
advance, and this is of course
exactly what he does not want to
do.
That said, on some level it's
impossible for us to read
Paradise Lost and not
assume that this God requires
vindication.
God seems in so many ways to be
responsible for the Fall,
and it might even be impossible
to read the story of the Fall in
Genesis and not attribute some
of the guilt to the Yahweh who
placed the forbidden fruit in
the garden in the first place.
Dr.
Johnson inadvertently here
reveals something about Milton's
poem that Milton himself perhaps
isn't willing or able to admit,
and that's that God appears to
be guilty and it's up to Milton
to clear him of any suspicion of
guilt.Look at the headnote
that Milton attaches to the
beginning of Book Three.
This is page 257 in the
Hughes.
And when Paradise Lost
initially appeared -- in its
original appearance in 1667,
these arguments,
or headnotes,
weren't there.
He added them to a later
printing presumably at the
request of a printer who thought
that the readers needed a little
help with the poem.
You actually may want to think
about it, this is an interesting
phenomenon and very little
written about:
the general relation between
these summarized arguments --
they're essentially plot
summaries -- to the actual
story,
the actual narrative that
follows in each book.
The beginning of this argument
strikes me as an especially
interesting one.
So this is Milton's argument
for Book Three.
God sitting on his Throne
sees Satan flying towards this
world, then newly created;
shows him to the Son,
who sat at his right hand;
foretells the success of Satan
in perverting mankind;
clears his own Justice and
Wisdom from all imputation,
having created Man free and
able enough to have withstood
his Tempter…
I'm just going to focus on a
couple of those clauses:
"foretells the success of Satan
in perverting mankind…"
Then we get Milton's semicolon,
and then, "clears his own
Justice and Wisdom from all
imputation..."
You kind of get the feeling
here -- at least I get the
feeling here -- that this
semicolon is working as hard as
it possibly can to yoke these
seemingly conflicting principles
together.
I'm not sure it's the case that
any semicolon is up to such an
enormous theological task.
In this formulation,
Milton seems to own up on some
level to Johnson's
characterization of the theodicy
of Paradise Lost as a
vindication.
God needs to clear his own
justice.
He needs to clear his name,
in essence because that name
has been clouded over with some
kind of suspicion.Now I take
this absolutely seriously that I
think it has to be seen as
authentic and sincere,
Milton's desire to justify God.
He needs to imagine a God who
can't be held responsible for
the Fall because only a
blameless God could be worthy of
Milton's praise or even worthy
of Milton's interest.
Frankly, I think that Milton
does a pretty decent job of
representing a God who cannot be
seen as some kind of guilty
coconspirator in the Fall of
man.
He does a pretty decent job
vindicating God,
but then when we think about
it,
there are few poets more adept
at the art of vindication than
John Milton.
Milton had been practicing the
art of vindication and the art
of defense, something like the
art of criminal defense,
all of his life.We looked
last time, on Monday,
at the lengths to which he went
in his poetry and his prose to
vindicate himself with regard to
his blindness;
but long before that,
before Milton's sight had been
cut off and long before his
tender orbs of vision had been
quenched,
to use his poetry,
Milton had been exercising his
talents in the rhetorical art of
self-defense.
In Sonnet Seven and actually
throughout the early works,
Milton was defending himself
against that fear,
you remember,
that God would punish him for
waiting so long to begin his
career,
that God was angry with Milton:
Milton was already twenty-three
years old and he had so little
to show for himself.
Later Milton devoted a good
deal of energy to other kinds of
defense.
He labored to vindicate the
radical Puritan left in England
when it was held that they had
committed a crime in killing the
king and in raising a hand
against God's anointed monarch,
when Europe was aghast at the
barbaric behavior of the English
revolutionaries.
Milton wrote in Latin for the
benefit of the entire European
intellectual community two
defenses of the crime of the
regicide.
He wrote a First Defense of
the English People and then
a work entitled the Second
Defense of the English
People,
and there is no
question that he would have been
capable, had there been time or
had there been interest,
of writing a third defense and
a fourth defense.
The labor of defense,
the work of vindication,
was something that Milton was
getting very good at and it
really goes to the core of his
intellectual
temperament.Now,
Milton lays the groundwork for
his sweeping vindication of God
in the discussion in Book Three
between the heavenly Father and
his Son.
This is essentially the same
theology that Milton will
establish in the theological
treatise that he's writing at
the same time that he's writing
Paradise Lost,
On Christian Doctrine,
parts of which were
assigned for today's class.
Now it's important for Milton
to establish something like --
and this is what he gets to do
in the venue of the prose
treatise as opposed to the poem:
he has the opportunity to
establish a theoretical basis
for a lot of his beliefs and
thus a theoretical basis for his
vindication of God.
He needs to prove
theologically,
not just poetically or
narratively, that God did not
place Adam and Eve in the garden
with the intent or with the
purpose in mind of punishing
them for eating the fruit.
He needs to convince himself
and he needs to convince his
reader, Milton does,
that the fact of God's
foreknowledge of the Fall
doesn't in any way cause the
Fall.
This is a huge worry not just
for Milton but for all
philosophically minded
Christians,
that the faculty of free will
is a genuine faculty -- this is
something that Milton really
needs to believe -- and that
it's not just some
papier-m&acir
c;ché concept pasted
together by a cynical and
manipulative deity or by a
cynical and manipulative
poet.In order to assert this
belief in a genuinely meaningful
faculty of free will,
Milton has to tackle head on
the theology of his fellow
Puritans, the prevailing
theology of his fellow Puritans.
Milton has to dismantle -- and
this is no easy task --
dismantle the Calvinist doctrine
of divine predestination.
Now the most prevalent belief
among Milton's contemporary
Puritans was this belief in
divine predestination.
Nearly all the men and women
that we can identify comfortably
as Puritans embrace the faith in
God's omnipotence outlined in
the works of John Calvin,
Calvin being the
sixteenth-century Swiss
theologian -- actually French
theologian -- living in Geneva
who insisted that everyone's
salvation could be traced back
ultimately to the predestinary
will of God.
For Calvin, God has not only
known since the beginning of
time what we will do,
but God actually causes us in
some sense to do what we do.
There's very little space for a
meaningful range of free will in
a strict Calvinist system.
It's God then who has for
Calvin elected in advance who
will be saved and who will be
damned;
and Calvin was justified -- or
at least he felt he was
justified, and many of his
followers felt he was justified
-- in this assertion of God's
control when he read the passage
from Saint Paul's Epistle to the
Romans.
This is the passage:
"For whom" -- oh,
let me read the whole thing.
This is Romans 8:29.
For whom he did foreknow,
he also did predestinate to be
conformed to the image of his
Son,
Moreover whom he did
predestinate,
them he also called:
and whom he called,
them he also justified:
and whom he justified,
them he also glorified.
"For whom he did foreknow,
he also did predestinate":
it's a perfectly devastating
Bible verse for anyone committed
to a strong stance as Milton was
in the Doctrine of Free Will.
On some level,
at least in this passage from
Saint Paul, Romans 8:29,
scripture seemed to provide
incontrovertible evidence for
the fact that God already
predestined the elect,
those Christians who had
arbitrarily at the very
foundation of time been elected
for salvation;
and that by extension God had
also -- and this is another
important component of the
Calvinist theological system --
arbitrarily marked another group
of men and women for punishment
and eternal damnation.It
seems incontrovertible,
but this course is about Milton
and, of course,
nothing is incontrovertible for
Milton.
You see him tangle with just
this passage,
this passage from the Book of
Romans, for two solid pages in
On Christian Doctrine.
You just have a sense that
Milton is saying,
"This can't possibly mean what
it seems to mean."
There's a genuine and powerful
urgency charging Milton's --
it's like a wrestling match,
almost, with a biblical passage
like this.
So one of the important
conclusions that Milton comes to
in his wrestling match with
scripture is that the term
"elect,"
as Saint Paul uses it in the
Bible, doesn't refer to God's
absolute predestination.
Actually, let me ask you to
turn to your Hughes.
This is page 921 of the
Christian Doctrine.
Milton writes that "I
conclude that believers are the
same as the elect,
and that the terms are used
indiscriminately."
I'm going to read that again:
"I conclude that believers are
the same as the elect,
and the terms are used
indiscriminately."
Believers are the elect and
because of course,
on some level we get to choose
whether or not we believe,
we therefore get to choose,
and we have some agency in,
whether or not we are going to
be one of God's elect.This
is one of Milton's most
compelling and really wonderful
perversions of mainstream
Calvinist theology.
Calvin had insisted on
predestination to assert God's
absolute control over his
creation and God's absolute
control over that final
separation at the end of time
between the saved and the
damned.
Calvin felt that his theology
was the least we owed to the
grandeur and the omnipotence of
God,
but for Milton to say that
believers are the same as the
elect is essentially,
I think, on some level to strip
God of that control.
It's as if Milton were
defending something like a
usurpation of God's authority,
and it's the same strategy that
you will see Milton employing
time and again.
It's the damndest thing:
he's able to take the most
depressingly constrictive
biblical doctrine and he turns
it into a proof for his own
faith in man's absolutely free
will.
Milton's philosophy of -- he's
not the only person doing this,
but he does it with more
ingenuity perhaps than just
about any of his contemporaries
-- of free will is often called
Arminianism.
Arminianism is named after the
sixteenth-century Dutch
theologian James Arminius;
I can't remember the Dutch name
off the top of my head,
but Jacobus Arminius is the
Latin name that he published
under.Now,
I've been speaking of the
theology of free will as if it
were simply a matter of
religious doctrine or
exclusively a matter of
religious doctrine.
Of course, probably more
importantly than any other way
it is a matter of religious
doctrine,
but religion -- and I think
this can be said not just for
Milton, it surely can be said
for all of us -- religion serves
a whole range of cultural
functions.
We saw last time some of the
deeply personal uses to which
Milton was able to put his
theology.
Just as he needs to prove that
God's omniscience and
omnipotence is not a sign of his
responsibility for the Fall,
Milton needed to prove that his
blindness wasn't a sign of God's
punishment of Milton.That
was a personal motivation for
some of the theological energies
of Milton's poem,
but I think more central to
Milton's theology than anything
like a personal motivation is
Milton's politics,
although the political sphere
is intimately intertwined with
anything that we would want to
think of as personal.
Theology and political
philosophy -- these obviously
seem to us such radically
distinct spheres of thought,
but they're incredibly closely
intertwined in the seventeenth
century, and I think there are
all sorts of political and
social motivations for Milton's
theology.
There are political and social
reasons for the fact that some
of the period's radical
intellectuals like Milton are
beginning radically to assert
the importance of man's free
will and,
beginning at the same time,
to diminish the authority that
had traditionally in the
Calvinist system been accorded
to God.
I think there's a political
significance to the period's
renewed attachment to and
investment in the philosophy or
the theology of Arminius who,
as you can see,
had died at the very beginning
of the seventeenth century.
Arminianism has a new wave,
maybe its third wave,
by the later part of the
seventeenth century.Now,
as we know from the treatise
Areopagitica and from
Milton's regicide writings as
well,
Milton was establishing himself
in the middle part of the
century as one of England's
foremost,
one of England's most
articulate, spokesmen for a
phenomenon that we can call,
although it's an anachronistic
term, liberalism.
And so obviously the word
liberalism hasn't emerged
yet, but you have something like
a theory of liberalism,
or at least a theory of
libertarianism,
beginning to assert itself in
the middle of the seventeenth
century.
You have a serious formulation
of liberalism later in the
seventeenth century shortly
after Milton dies with the
philosopher John Locke,
who was a great reader of
Milton.
Traditional Renaissance
political thought before Locke,
and I think you can say before
Milton, was more or less
authoritarian.
It placed a monarch at the top
of the society,
at the top of the polity.
Traditional Renaissance
political thought needed to
imagine that monarch's control,
his ultimate governance over
the behavior and the actions of
all of the individuals in that
society -- this political
philosophy invariably asserted
the importance of a radical
image of centralization of
power.
It's really not until the
middle of the seventeenth
century that Europeans -- and
it's not just Englishmen -- are
beginning to articulate any
serious alternative to the
authoritarian,
centralized model of political
organization.
There are people on the radical
left, and Milton is one of them,
who begin to posit the idea
that the disbursed individuals
throughout a society can be
reasonably depended on to govern
themselves with sufficient
self-control.Of course,
such a theory assumes a lot of
things.
It assumes a sufficient degree
of self-control that every
individual would have.
With this self-control,
rational individuals could
organize themselves without a
king, without the top-down
hierarchical structure of a
monarchy.
This position is most often
associated in England,
at least in the middle of the
century, with the Levellers.
The Levellers are the
high-minded intellectual
component of the army during the
English Revolution during the
middle of the seventeenth
century,
and the leveler theory of
sovereignty is something like an
elected sovereignty.
If there is a sovereign,
that sovereign will be elected
or chosen by the people;
the sovereign's not going to be
imposed upon the people.
So election in a lot of ways is
not simply a theological term,
obviously to this day.
It has political resonances as
well.So this brand-new
liberal -- what I'm calling a
liberal-- theology is not only
political in nature.
However, it's also economic.
It's precisely the same period,
the mid-seventeenth century,
when something like –
again, I'll use the term
anachronistically -- when
something like a liberal market
theory of economic exchange is
being theorized.
I'll give you a brief history
of economic thought in the early
modern period.
Up until this point,
it was assumed that the only
efficient way to organize the
economic life of a nation was to
have the monarch -- the
sovereign,
the authoritarian center of the
government -- fix prices and
determine the value of currency:
in general,
to oversee the dynamics of just
about all economic exchange.
But suddenly -- and this really
is happening in the 1650s and
it's happening first in England
-- suddenly a liberal economic
theory is coming into view.
It was being conjectured that
individuals, meaning individual
merchants, could freely set
prices and values according to
the law of supply and demand
rather than according to the law
of the authoritarian will of the
king.
There's a wonderful book on
this subject by Joyce Appleby if
any of you are interested.
I can't remember what it's
called, but you'll figure out
[laughs]
from Orbis [the Yale library
search engine]
which of Joyce Appleby's
wonderful books this is.
The argument is essentially
that a free-market philosophy
had simply been unthinkable.
Free free-market philosophy
that we just take as a given
almost was unthinkable before
the middle years of the
seventeenth century.So,
you have these two enormous
shifts in the way that English
intellectuals were thinking
about their political and also
about their economic lives.
It seems to me that it only
stands to reason that there's
going to be a corresponding
shift or some sort of related
shift on the level of religious
thought.
If individuals are going to be
liberated from their earthly
monarch, if merchants are going
to be liberated from the
centralizing power of the
sovereign in charge of the
economy,
then individual souls are going
to have to be liberated at least
to some extent from the
predestinary stronghold of the
heavenly monarch as well -- as
if intellectual life could
operate with these huge
analogous forms.
I think that that's one of the
functions of Milton's insistence
on his liberal theology of free
will.
It's as if he needs to bring
his religion in line with his
liberal politics.Now,
let's look at the dialogue in
heaven.
Turn to page 260 in the
Hughes.
This is Book Three,
line ninety-three.
It's here in the dialogue in
heaven between the Father and
the Son where so many of the
tensions between Calvinist
predestination and Miltonic free
will get worked out -- but let
me digress for a moment.
Before we actually look at the
dialogue, I think it's important
to ask why it is -- and I think
people have been asking this
question ever since people have
been reading Paradise Lost
-- why it is that God the
Father and God the Son need to
be holding a dialogue at all.
"What is it that they need to
say to one another?"
I think we can reasonably
ask.For orthodox Christians
in Milton's time and I think for
a lot of orthodox Christians in
our time,
the Father and the Son are
members of what's known as the
Trinity.
The Father, the Son and the
Holy Spirit are paradoxically --
according to most Trinitarian
thinking -- three separate
entities,
but they are also most
importantly one unified entity.
Because they are all one and
all equally one,
it borders almost on blasphemy
to imagine the Father and the
Son needing to discuss anything,
but Milton realized that -- and
this was an extraordinary and
bold move on his part -- Milton
argued that there was no basis
in scripture for belief in the
Trinity;
people had always known that
the word Trinity actually
appears nowhere in the
scripture.
You can see Milton in the
Christian Doctrine
supplying mountains,
literally mountains,
of scriptural evidence to
disprove the Christian doctrine
of the Trinity.Milton took
very seriously the biblical
metaphors of Father and Son.
The Father and the Son are not
aspects of the same deity.
They are literally for Milton a
father and a son,
and when God refers in
scripture to "my only begotten
Son" or to "my first begotten
son" he really means it,
according to Milton.
The Father generates the Son.
He gives birth to Him at a
specific moment in pre-creation
history, and Milton is therefore
-- he has been called a
subordinationist.
He subordinates the Son to the
Father because the Son will
never be -- or at least not
until the very end of time --
will never be the Father's
equal;
and so the Son can in no way be
imagined identical or equal to
the Father.
The Father can when he chooses
-- and this happens in
Paradise Lost -- he can
grant a certain measure of power
to the Son,
but the Son in no way possesses
any kind of power that hasn't
been granted to him at God's
pleasure.
The Son nothing like the
foreknowledge or omnipotence
that the Father has.Now,
we see the Son doing things,
performing actions,
in Paradise Lost.
For example,
he's responsible for having
created or serving as the
vehicle for the creation of the
entire known universe:
not negligible perhaps,
but he can only perform these
God-like feats and he can only
be called God-like,
not actually God,
when the Father permits him to
perform such feats.
He needs his Father's
permission and,
like Adam and Eve,
it's beholden upon the Son to
obey the Father.
This is crucial to Milton's
theology.
Look at how all these
essentially domestic relations
get theologized in the dialogue
in heaven, line ninety-three of
Book Three.
The Father of course -- and it
just drives me crazy -- the
Father speaks in the future
tense of absolute foreknowledge
because he can;
and you're right to think -- I
hope you've thought -- that
there's something a little
chilling about the Father's
discursive manner here,
the way in which he can shift
so easily between the past tense
and the future tense.
So, line ninety-three.
This is the Father:
For Man will heark'n to
his [Satan's]
glozing lies,And easily
transgress the sole Command,
Sole pledge of his
obedience: So will fallHee
and his faithless Progeny:
whose fault?Whose but his
own?
ingrate [Ouch!
Whose fault?
Whose but his own?],
he had of meeAll he could
have;
I made him just and
right,Sufficient to have
stood, though free to
fall.Such I created all th'
Etheral PowersAnd Spirits,
both them who stood and them
who fail'd;Freely they stood
who stood, and fell who
fell.
Now, I'm going to set aside
here, because I can't deal with
it, this little outburst that
seems so incredibly indecorous
and inappropriate,
"ingrate."
I am going to discuss instead
the last line that I just read,
which indicates,
I think, one of the central
rhetorical strategies of the
Father's speech.
Now look at line ninety-nine
first.
There's something liberating
about the Father's credo here:
" sufficient to have stood,
though free to fall."
This is kind of rousing and,
as rousing as this is,
the Father doesn't leave it
there.
He broaches the subject of the
fallen angels and he repeats the
same formulation,
but he repeats it with a
difference.
Look at line 101.
He's just discussed both them
who stood and them who failed:
"freely they stood who stood,
and fell who fell."
The Father recasts that
original statement within a
repetitive rhetoric.
It's essentially a repetitive
rhetoric of tautology,
and in so doing,
I think he exposes something of
the highly schematic nature of
his sense of justice.This
last line is often cited in
Milton criticism as a positive
example of Milton's commitment
to the doctrine of free will,
but I don't really buy it.
I'm not convinced by the
Father's statement.
This line may begin with that
exuberant adverb "freely," but
the rest of it,
at least to me,
smacks of something like
predestination.
It's a little depressing.
They stood who stood and fell
who fell -- is it a stretch to
extrapolate from that a
paraphrase like this:
the type of person who was
created to stand did stand and
created to fall did fall?
There's something
disconcertingly programmatic
about the Father's repetition
here,
the repetitiveness of his
explanation, and the
tautological force of this
formulation seems to rob the
opening word of the line
"freely" of some of its
liberatory energy.Okay.
That was the Father's speech.
Wonderfully,
the Son seems almost to recoil
from the rigidity of the
Father's position.
In fact, he seems actually to
soften the Father a little.
He asks the Father to show
mercy toward man since man,
like the Son himself,
is a son of God.
It's at this point you get the
Father's -- [laughs]
and you want to throttle him --
the Father's condescending claim
that of course he knew all along
that the Son would be asking for
mercy.
Milton is obliged to make the
Father omniscient,
of course, because the Father
is omniscient,
although the entire drama of
this dialogue [laughs]
is structured,
as any drama or any dialogue
has to be structured,
to suggest that there are two
individuals who are reacting
genuinely to one another's
speeches because they don't know
in advance what the other is
going to say.
That's what a dialogue is,
but there's clearly a powerful
asymmetry here in this dialogue,
and the asymmetry threatens,
I think, to cast this entire
scene into something like a
potentially ridiculous light;
but the Son does seem at least
to have made a kind of impact on
the Father.
The Father seems to relent,
and the Father agrees to accept
the repentance of Adam and
Eve.Look at line 194.
This is at the top of page 263.
The Father promises to show
mercy and he promises to permit
Adam and Eve a safe journey back
into his good graces.
So line 194:
And I will place within
them as a guideMy Umpire
Conscience, whom if they will
hear,
Light after light well us'd
they shall attain,And to the
end persisting,
safe arrive.
It's as if the Father has been
cajoled by the Son,
cajoled out of his repetitive
cyclicality and nudged toward
something like a more linear
and,
to my taste,
a more palatable form of human
progress.
I think we sigh with relief at
the knowledge that all will be
well again after the Fall.
We have all the earmarks here
of a narrative,
moving from a beginning,
through a middle,
toward an end.
We sigh with relief at the
knowledge that everything is
going to be okay.But of
course, this relief is only
momentary.
As soon as the Father has
agreed to this concession,
as soon as he's promised their
safe journey back to God,
he adds a condition,
and this condition appears at
line 203.
This is near the top of page
263.
He returns to that rhetoric of
repetition and equivalence that
had marked his earlier speech;
"but yet all is not
done…":
[W]ell us'd they shall
attain,
And to the end
persisting, safe arrive.
[It did seem pretty much all
was done but there's some
backtracking here.]
…But yet all
is not done;
Man disobeying,Disloyal
breaks his fealty,
and sinsAgainst the high
Supremacy of Heav'n,
Affecting God-head,
and so loosing all,To
expiate his Treason hath naught
left,
But to destruction sacred
and devote,He with his whole
posteritie must die,Die hee
or Justice must;
unless for himSome other
able, and as willing,
payThe rigid satisfaction,
death for death.
"But yet all is not done":
you can almost hear Milton in
this line catching himself and
realizing that man,
of course, wasn't redeemed
simply because Adam and Eve were
repentant, simply because they
said they were sorry.
It has the same force as that
incredibly startling moment in
the Nativity Ode when Milton
tells us,
"But wisest Fate says No,
/ this must not yet be so."
Although he certainly [laughs]
gives it a shot,
he can't get away from the
unhappy fact that man was not
redeemed simply because Adam and
Eve said they were sorry.
Man was redeemed through the
much more troubling,
for Milton, mechanism of the
Father's sacrifice of the Son.
Milton has successfully avoided
finishing his poem about the
crucifixion, "The Passion,"
the poem called "The
Passion," when he was a
young man.
It just went unfinished.
As you read the dialogue in
heaven in Book Three of
Paradise Lost,
for a while at least,
it seems that Milton is going
to be able to evade the entire
question of the sacrifice one
more time -- but he catches
himself: "But yet all is not
done."
He forces a consideration of
the atonement,
of the crucifixion,
and it's crucial to
understanding exactly how it is
that Milton here is imagining
the dynamics of the
redemption.So Milton first
of all has to reject the
orthodox understanding of the
Christian redemption.
I'll remind you what that looks
like.
In the New Testament,
and for a lot of Christian
theologians, the redemption
seems to work along the lines of
something like a revenge
sacrifice and,
as cultural anthropologists
have taught us,
there is something like a
primitive logic,
an intensely primitive logic,
at work behind the notion of
the Christian notion of the
crucifixion.
One of the Father's sons,
Adam, has died and so the
Father will avenge that death by
murdering someone else.
Of course, that means murdering
another son.
This model of redemption is
based on the repetition,
or a repetition,
of the initial crime,
and this logic of repetition,
I think, is largely responsible
for that rhetoric of
repetitiveness that we hear so
often in the Father's speech.
According to this -- we can
think of it as a sacrifice
theory of redemption or of the
atonement,
God chooses to sacrifice his
son since someone is going to
have to be punished for Adam's
sin.
The logic demands that.But
Milton, I think,
can imagine no aspect of his
religion,
no aspect of Christianity,
more barbaric than the image of
the Father's willing sacrifice
of his son.
This would be a God truly
unworthy of Milton's
justification.
Milton's struggling here,
and there are a few of his
contemporaries who are doing the
same thing in the seventeenth
century.
He's struggling to bring
Christianity in line with
certain standards of rationality
and, as Dr.
Johnson had said,
in the rest of the sentence
that I wrote on the board,
Milton wants to show the
reasonableness of religion;
and so Milton replaces the
sacrifice model of the
redemption with something like a
satisfaction model of
redemption.
According to this way of
thinking, in Adam's sin,
a debt has been incurred,
and this debt can be satisfied
by someone else's payment so
revenge is no longer the motive.
It's something like an economic
desire simply to balance the
books.There is something
impersonal about this new way of
imagining the atonement,
and it's here that Milton gives
the notion of the Christian
redemption its particular
Miltonic twist.
Milton's Father does not
willingly sacrifice the Son.
It's magnificent:
he simply asks for a volunteer,
and the Son out of his goodness
volunteers.
He chooses to make himself
mortal.
It's a perfect example of how
Milton has shifted the emphasis
away from Christian orthodoxy
and forced the authoritarian
image of God's sacrifice to
yield to Milton's liberal image
of a kind of volunteerism or
libertarian image of
volunteerism.
The Son chooses to humiliate
himself and subsequently God
chooses to compensate that
humiliation with the Son's
supreme exaltation.
You see the extent of this
compensation at line 311 in Book
Three, page 265 near the bottom
of the page.
God says to the Son:
Because in theeLove
hath abounded more than Glory
abounds,Therefore thy
Humiliation shall exaltWith
thee thy Manhood also to this
Throne;Here shalt thou sit
incarnate,
here shalt ReignBoth God
and Man, Son both of God and
Man,Anointed universal King;
all PowerI give thee,
reign for ever,
and assumeThy Merits;
under thee as Head
SupremeThrones,
Princedoms, Powers,
Dominions I
reduce…
To reward the Son for having
sacrificed himself,
the Father is going to give the
Son all power.
It seems like it's going to be
a complete transference of
power, and it's a transfer that
will hold until at the end of
time.
There will no longer even be a
difference presumably between
the Father and the Son because,
as the Father says at line 341,
"God shall be All in All."
There will be no power
differential whatsoever between
the Father and the Son,
and presumably there'll be no
power differential between or
among any of us.
We'll all be joined at the end
of time in one massive liberal,
nonhierarchical state of
harmony.
The image of the "All in All"
is Milton's most exuberant
visionary endpoint,
and it satisfies,
I think, a lot of Milton's most
liberal impulses.
Even the authoritarian
structure of heaven -- and of
course, Milton's heaven is as
authoritarian as any heaven has
ever been conceived -- even it
will be transformed into
something like a fantasy of
egalitarianism,
a fantasy of absolute equality.
This ecstatic redistribution of
power and glory at the end of
time can only come about because
the Son has willingly humiliated
himself.
He subjects himself to the
Father's wrath.I think we
recognize this gesture,
this image of the noble and
voluntary self-sacrifice.
This is the matter:
this is the image that Milton
had established in his defenses
of his blindness.
Milton had written in the
sonnet that we looked at on
Monday to Mr.
Cyriack Skinner,
and he had also written in the
Second Defense of the English
People,
that he had willingly
sacrificed his sight for the
good of his fellow Englishmen.
He lost his eyes "overplied in
liberty's defence,
my noble task," Milton had
written in that sonnet.
In the Second
Defense, Milton
explains that he continued to
write his regicide treatises
despite the advice of his
doctors who insisted that he
would go blind if he continued
-- that's how important the
project was for Milton and the
sacrifice.
You begin to see a way in which
the two dominant features of
Book Three, Milton's invocation
to light and the discussion of
blindness therein and the dialog
between the Father and the Son,
are speaking to one another and
they're functioning in a kind of
parallel fashion.Just as the
Son's voluntary sacrifice will
be rewarded with his
inheritance,
on some level the heavenly plot
of Paradise Lost is
essentially an inheritance
narrative.
The Son's voluntary sacrifice
will be rewarded with his
inheritance of all of God's
power.
Presumably too,
Milton's sacrifice will also be
rewarded by God.
It's as if Milton wants the
same compensation of paternal
power that the Son had been
granted for undergoing his
sacrifice.Let me see what I
have time for.
The transfusion of divine power
that Milton imagines,
the transfer of power from
Father to the Son,
if extrapolated to the
situation of the poet and his
God, would guarantee the
inspired success of the poem.
What would that mean?
It would guarantee essentially
the status of Paradise Lost
as scripture itself,
as something divinely
authorized or perhaps even
divinely authored.
That, at least,
is its relation to Milton's
personal concern with his own
composition of Paradise
Lost,
but this image of a
kind of divine transfusion of
power and an ultimate
transference of power also,
I think, speaks to the
political component of Milton's
theology.
You have in this passage an
image of a transfer of power
from a centralized authority,
the creator of the entire
universe, to the humble
individual.
The image supplies essentially
the conceptual foundation for
Milton's liberalism,
that form of social
organization whereby power has
been shifted away from the
center,
away from the monarch,
and toward the subject.
You will find images of
inheritance and of transference
and of transfusion abounding in
Paradise Lost;
they crop up in all sorts of
venues, often having nothing
whatsoever to do with the
domestic interactions of the
godhead.These images prepare
us for that beautiful but truly
outrageous endpoint of Christian
history that Milton foresees,
the one that God had foretold
in his speech to the Son.
There will come a point in time
in which God shall be "All in
All."
That's an idea that works on
the level of theology to satisfy
nearly every desire;
to satisfy the personal,
the social, and the political
desires of what we can,
I think, not entirely wrongly
think of as Milton's idea of the
liberal Christian.Okay.
I'm going to end there.
We will all read very closely
Book Four for Wednesday's class.